No, I had never
witnessed a tragedy of this
magnitude.
I have been in this career for 20 years and I
had never had such a tragic road accident. He
was involved in the massacre in El
Paso, Texas, but I was in Mexico and
well, I went there, I was with the families,
but anyway.  It is a different situation,
this is a car accident
that should not have happened for any
reason.
The message that we have repeated many
times is that people should
drive carefully or they should not abuse
substances, much less illicit ones, or
consume them.
I spoke  with the family they are
devastated as we are by their
loss
and our goal is to help help
the family and help all the families
who lose a loved one in las
vegas' and of course in all of nevada
because this consulate covers everything  nevada
I think she felt a little relieved
because she felt and received the support of
the Mexican government of her country and her
consulate, we will be
assisting  When
issuing documents, a
certificate of transit of remains is needed to
enter Mexico. If they require
financial assistance, they will also receive it and,
of course, general guidance, because
at this time, families
are always very sad,
they feel overwhelmed, so they can
trust.  in us that we are going to give them
the most
correct information so that they can continue with the
procedures and so they can have a closure
of this terrible situation because it is
basically giving them the information to talk
to the funeral home talk to the family
do everything as quickly as possible
us in fact  We issue these
transit visas in a couple of hours, it is
even a free procedure, so
there will be no impediment on our part,
everything will be expeditious and
what the family requires, I personally
am going to give my condolences to the
family.  and I will be with them at the funeral
if they have an accident or a
deceased person, do not hesitate to call us
We are going to provide
truthful objective information about the institutions that
can support you in the event of a death.
We work with various
funeral homes that have low or
affordable costs because there are funeral homes, there are
everything, some are very expensive, and there are some that
have normal prices.  and then there are those
funeral homes that have affordable prices
that also have experience in the
process of sending remains to mexico so
that first step is very important
because sometimes families sign a
contract with a funeral home that will
charge them a lot of money and then  There are
some problems when families
have financial need, they do not have
money to send the remains to Mexico,
we can help them, we
help only when families
decide to send remains to Mexico, if the
funeral is here, we are not
allowed to support financially, but the
message is very clear.  We are always going to
help you, we are always going to guide you,
so please continue  n being very careful
with the shelter with the driving of the
cars with the accidents in the
job to
hire your loved ones well
domestic violence is a
very serious problem in our community it must
be eradicated so my message is
that the consulate of  Mexico is open
there are multiple ways to
contact us we have a
cell phone that is open 24/7
we are here from 8 to 5 every
day we have social networks we have
phones we have the website
so in my opinion there is no excuse
not to contact us
here we are to serve you